a 2012's last time I shaved by Drogo
fire decree ah yes Jason Momoa has
shaved his beard and while we know some
of you are probably well heartbroken the
good news is he documented the moment
for the world to see and it's for a good
cause there's only one thing you really
help our planet and save our planet
as long as we recycle that's aluminium
that's right he's making it change cuz
he wants to see change by raising
awareness about how harmful plastic is
and let's be honest not all change is
bad cuz Jason looks good
please please
there's a change coming that's aluminium
you got to get rid of these plastic
water bottles I'll come and try to do
the best I can my kids through their
kids the world the ocean snowboarding
love you guys
now we know this couldn't have been easy
for him he's literally had his beard
since 2012 two of his most famous
big-screen characters were known for
their signature beards Aquaman good
buddy you got fish boy from the TV it's
this man and Cal Drago from Game of
Thrones Khal Drogo or Aquaman what's
cooler and clearly his wife Lisa Bonet
was a fan of the beard look we know this
wasn't easy for the internet either fans
had a lot to say but fun fact Jason
actually got his start beard list on
Baywatch he did almost 50 episodes Jason
no mister just Jason yeah can you
believe that's Jason come on help me out
here sound a little crazy but you were
on Baywatch from 99 to 2001 brother
basin
yes Joseph does that repair you at all
for being Aquaman in that realm no no no
I mean I think being a Hawaiian baby
I mean I've been in I've been in the
ocean you know since I was a baby and
might come from a long lineage of
Waterman and here's the good news all
hair grows back what do you guys think
of Jason's new look though let us know
and of course be sure to subscribe to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now